Плоди оливи майже стиглі.
Пеп Андреу розраховує на щедрий врожай.
Чоловік сподівається, що рух за незалежність Каталонії
теж нарешті дасть плоди.
Врешті-решт, люди в Монблані
давно за неї борються.
Пеп Андреу впевнений, що Каталонія
не повинна більше бути донором
для економічно менш успішних регіонів Іспанії.
Платити завжди доводиться нам.
Так більше не може тривати.
Фінансові потоки повинні розподілятись інакше.
Хто більше виробляє, повинен і більше отримувати.
В муніципалітеті Монблан більшість жителів -
"за" незалежність Каталонії.
А от Педро Наварро інакше оцінює
прагнення до незалежності. Він переймається
через свій бізнес. Педро продає
машинобудівельне обладнання і запчастини у всій Іспанії.
Чоловік навіть уявити боїться,
що Каталонія може опинитись в ізоляції.
Авжеж, я хвилююсь.
Через те, що ми можемо стати незалежними і
вийти з Іспанії. Мене непокоїть, що я не розумію,
в який бік ми рухаємося, що з нами буде.
Але я знаю, хто я, і де я живу: в Каталонії.
Питання про незалежність Каталонії
розкололо суспільство.
Одні хочуть відокремитися від Іспанії,
Інші бояться, що економіка зазнає збитків,
і хочуть залишити все, як є.
Деякі великі компанії вже оголосили про плани
перенести штаб-квартири з Каталонії в інші регіони Іспанії.
Це змушує сумніватися навіть
переконаних прихильників незалежності.
Шкода, заподіяна каталонському народу, розкол -
все це на сумлінні політиків.
Це вони підбурювали людей.
У Монблані політики теж закликали людей
до відокремлення від Іспанії.
На місцевій ратуші давно вже немає
іспанського прапора. Мер -  непохитний борець
за незалежність Каталонії.
З часів промислової революції нас відрізняє
особливий дух підприємництва.
Дайте нам самостійно розвиватися -
і побачимо, як через 2-3 роки ми станемо
одним із найважливіших економічних регіонів Європи.
Підприємець Педро Наварро в це не вірить.
Мені боляче це бачити, адже
мої батьки приїхали сюди 50 років тому,
щоб тут працювати.
І я всім зобов'язаний їм,
їм і іншим андалузцям,
які працювали на благо Каталонії.
Але для фермера Пепа Андреу такі люди, як Педро,
які переїхали з інших регіонів Іспанії,
не є справжніми каталонцями.
Щонайменше доти, доки
не виступають за незалежність.
Власник оливкової плантації хоче,
щоб Каталонія скористалася хвилею виступів
за незалежність. Інакше це може затягтися
ще на 300 років.